We have all been lied to
Men and women have been lied to
It's so easy for us to compare ourselves with other couples online
compare ourselves with other women who get “princess treatment”
bragging about their men paying for their nails, hair, shopping sprees
I am going to be brutally honest with you
that is not princess treatment
princess treatment is how he can support you and emotionally validate you
he's patient with you, he won't let you go to bed upset
You feel safe and vulnerable with him
and he doesn't raise his voice towards you
You can bring up any concerns that you have without him getting upset
because he can handle it
he can handle anything that you throw at him emotionally
he'll handle it with logic and reason
empathy and patience he tries to understand you
princess treatment is how he talks to you
how he touches you
I'm not afraid to admit that I like when I get spoiled with gifts
makes most women happy and elated
but I still don't consider that princess treatment
I think we all need to stop letting social media convince us
that princess treatment is in lavish gifts
or things that you buy because princess treatment
true princess treatment cannot be bought